so one of the things I loved about the
show is that it shows that even if you
have a power it might not be as
necessarily awesome as you think it
would be
um so if you could pick any of the
powers depicted in the show even knowing
the drawbacks like um accidentally
giving your dad an orgasm or getting
your butt stuck in the wall right which
one would you choose
oh which one would we choose I think the
helium one would be quite handy wouldn't
it yeah because you just blow up
balloons whatever he wanted
I have all the powers
his voice always sounds like that so I'm
gonna take that one back I'm gonna I'm
gonna start again
teleporting there's a character who
teleports oh yes I don't want to give
too much away oh yeah yeah there's a
character who's able to teleport and I
think that would be yeah very useful
because I'm quite bad at leaving the
house I'm quite late eight often because
I can't I always I'm like oh I leave the
house I forgot my shoes so I go back and
put them on but so I just be able to
teleport out of that would be great with
shoes yeah I think teleporting with
probably coolest anybody else ever
thought I think shape-shifting I would
like shape-shifting but if I was to be
really specific I wouldn't just like to
shape-shift into a cat I'd like to
shape-shift into other animals as well
specifically aquatic animals like
dolphin sharks so I like to build a
shape ship
dolphins and sharks if you had to choose
what would it be Dolphins yeah yeah
you've got I feel like you've got
dolphin energy as well do you know yeah
I do see that you're not a shark
speaking of the shape Thing Luke um
tell me this was a real cat
and
was it a real cat on the show yes uh a
real cat named Annie
um occupation my rival
um there was uh yeah there was a time
when yeah my dressing room had a sign
that said jizzled the human and I spent
ages trying to work out wedges Lord the
cat stressing room once turns out it was
a small box
um so I won that round
um but also the cat got a little massage
every day yeah a massage every time she
would go on set so how did you um how
did you prepare to play a cat
yeah it's it's the the thing is is that
like
because
the cat I I never actually obviously I'm
not portraying the cat but I'm someone
who transforms out from being a cat
although a lot of people I've spoken to
about it all of them just think that I'm
in like a fursuit no matter how many
times I explain like oh no absolutely
turns into a man they think I've been
walking around going like meow meow meow
meow
um that's my impression and that's why I
didn't get the role that went to Annie
oh
um but come on pay attention
um so uh yeah to play like yeah like the
the to it's an interesting role to play
because he arrives in this environment
and he doesn't know anything about what
he's doing and he's like completely lost
right and even physically he's not even
really used to his body yet and that
kind of corresponded to how I felt
suddenly being on this set of this
amazing show for all of us this is like
our first big role and
um I kind of felt a bit like oh my God
like where the hell am I what am I doing
like all of you guys had to pretend it
was totally normal or is at least for me
as an actor
um I felt quite disorientated so in in
many ways the perfect preparation was
just not knowing what I was doing and
since it was all of you I guess your
first leading role what What attracted
you to the project what made you want to
be a part of it I mean immediately like
the writing the writing of it is just
like so brilliant and it feels quite
like unique in that I think it's
um like the humor of it is quite current
like it's quite like our age group very
like current but somehow Emma has
written it that like I feel like it's
gonna be relatable for loads of
different age groups whether you've been
through this period of your life or
whether it's like ahead ahead for you
um and I mean the characters are so
funny like the first scene that I read
was the interview scene at the very
start and I was just like this is
absolutely hilarious like the idea that
this girl just has to like uh yeah she
can't help but be completely honest and
everything just completely blurts out
and it's kind of unapologetically honest
um was yeah and not sugar-coated yeah so
what about the rest here Sofia what what
you're doing
um I think very similar like it felt
very fresh and different and as soon as
I read the scripts I was kind of like
laughing out loud and it just felt I
just felt very excited when I read the
scripts in the world that Emma has
created
um it just felt something yeah I felt
like something I really wanted to be
part of and it felt very original and
different and he I think she's got such
a unique voice and the way she writes is
so specific
um it felt like
a kind of golden opportunity
um to be part of some yeah something
like that I mean something I really love
about it is that it feels like it's this
absurd world where people have these
like crazy Powers but also those Powers
often end up
being like a reflection of that
character's like own insecurities about
themselves or their own like struggles
in their own life as of course it would
be so on one hand it's short so quite
magical but also like it's it's so it's
so real and like rooted in like the very
mundane world and I find that like
really uh something really beautiful
about the show like your character for
example yeah you know he he's always
wants everything to be perfect so he
keeps on trying to go back time and and
make things work
um that ends up of course being like his
his downfall really you know yeah so
what was what was each of your favorite
episodes
do we all have the same favorite episode
to shoot or to watch
to shoot I guess
I guess okay then that might be
different yeah
that's four four I would say oh but then
I love the school as well so much fun
I was there for one season
might be embarrassing when we fell in
front of oh yes
the opening scene in episode five is
Carrie's having like a a fantasy
daydream about like her giving this
amazing speeches a returning alumna to
her secondary school and uh Akash comes
in and is like Praises her sort of
elocution and her rhetoric and then like
twists her around and like gives her a
kiss makes me bent it down and gives her
a kiss and we rehearsed in front of the
50 supporting artists that were supposed
to be watching this speech and I we
literally just fell on top of each other
and onto the floor in front of all these
all these people that we've never met
before didn't you see that there was
just like there wasn't it like it was a
gas yeah there was a gas none of them
was it wasn't even though we were
completely fine we're like it's fine
guys they all went everyone
laugh at all in my favorite episodes
okay but I really appreciate you guys
taking a few minutes to talk with me
thank you thank you so much everybody
[Music]